S’il y a bien une civilisation qui a marqué
l’imaginaire romantique occidental c’est
celle des les Mayas.
Ces cités sans habitants englouties par la
végétation, ces temples abandonnés aux
hiéroglyphes mystérieux sont devenus l’archétype
de la découverte archéologique et ont connu
une postérité parfois assez improbable.
Bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce premier
épisode de la rentrée où nous allons nous
intéresser à la disparition des Mayas.
Tout commence par la mission d’exploration
par John Lloyd Stephens et Frederick Catherwood,
menée entre 1839 et 1841.
Ce qui est au départ une mission diplomatique
permet finalement la redécouverte de plusieurs
cités perdues.
Certains sites avait déjà été décrits
par des voyageurs, tel que celui de Copán
par un colonel de l’armée guatémaltèque
quelques années plus tôt, mais tout cela
reste assez confidentiel pour le grand public.
C’est là que notre Catherwood intervient.
Il est dessinateur et aquarelliste, il a déjà
voyagé au Moyen-Orient et ses panoramas de
ruines antiques ont déjà fasciné le public
londonien.
Ces lithographies dessins et peintures sont
publiées dans un bouquin Incidents of Travel
in Central America et montrent ces ruines
antiques désertées aux inscriptions étranges.
C’est vraiment à partir de ce moment là
que le public est conquis et se passionne
pour la mystérieuse disparition des mayas.
Les récits farfelus vont très vite arriver,
pour n’en citer qu’un, celui de James
Churchward en 1932 qui fait de ces ruines
l’œuvre des habitants du mythique continent
de Mu.
Essayons de comprendre cette fascination.
A la différence des Aztèques, les grandes
cités mayas n’ont pas été attaquées
par les espagnols au XVIe siècle.
Elles étaient déjà abandonnées à cette
époque et c’est pourquoi elles ont pu incarner
un certain mystère : pour une fois, les européens
n’y étaient pour rien et on avait là des
sites archéologiques « purs » en quelque
sorte.
Il n’y a donc pas de grand récit détaillé
de la conquête comme celui de Bernal Diaz
del Castillo pour les Aztèques.
On a bien des archives sur les conquêtes,
notamment celle du dernier royaume Itzá à
la toute fin du XVIIe siècle, mais cette
histoire reste assez peu diffusée.
La raison principale de cet engouement teinté
de mystère pour les mayas est à mon avis
le décalage entre ces imposants vestiges
qui appellent une explication et l’absence
de récit historique aussi linéaire que celui
des Aztèques.
Ces derniers ont été conquis en deux ans.
Rien de tel pour les mayas.
Mais cela ne nous donne pas les raisons de
cette disparition.
De nombreux auteurs, pas tous archéologues
d’ailleurs, comme Jared Diamond dont je
reparlerai tout à l’heure, se sont penchés
sur cette question.
Mais avant d’aller plus loin, je vais vous
donner quelques repères chronologiques : les
ruines qui servent de support à notre imaginaire
sont de la période dite Classique s’étendant
environ entre 300 et 900 ap.
J.-C., notre haut-moyen-âge en quelque sorte.
A la fin de la période les cités des basses
terres, capitales des grands royaumes, périclitent
tandis que le nord de la péninsule du Yucatan
prospère un temps, avant de sombrer à son
tour.
L’effondrement de la civilisation classique
a été un véritable aiguillon pour la recherche
et cela a engendré de nombreux débats chez
les spécialistes et dans toutes les théories
que j’ai pu lire à ce sujet et bien on
peut distinguer quelques facteurs principaux
Les archéologues constatent un état de guerre
généralisé à la fin de la période, on
voit les villages se fortifier, les installations
humaines recherchent les reliefs pour se retrancher,
on bâtit de vastes réseaux de murailles,
il semble que toute la société ait été
affectée par de graves conflits.
L’organisation du monde maya en cités-états
rivales était en effet propice au conflit,
les élites royales tentaient par ce moyen
d’acquérir du prestige, mais cela aurait-il
pu dégénérer au point de faire disparaître
les royaumes ? D’autres scientifiques ont
avancé l’hypothèse de guerres externes
notamment par l’ouest du pays car on voit
apparaître de nouveaux styles de poteries
notamment à cette époque.
Alors le coup de la poterie ça peut sembler
insignifiant mais c’est bien souvent un
indice d’invasion pour les archéologues.
Mais cette dernière hypothèse est en partie
abandonnée de nos jours grâce aux travaux
archéologiques, la mutation observée s’est
probablement déroulée sur place.
Autre théorie, un grave changement climatique
serait survenu, entraînant sécheresse, famine,
et donc de violentes guerres pour le contrôle
des ressources.
Les analyses archéo-environnementales viennent
une nouvelle fois contredire ce schéma, aucune
trace de cataclysme environnemental, seulement
quelques épisodes difficiles, mais leur lien
avec les effondrements est incertain.
Alors, la pression du l’environnement, c’est
une théorie populaire, mettant en avant la
surpopulation qui aurait entraîné une surexploitation
de la forêt et des sols.
Ces phénomènes de dégradation de l’environnement
sont identifiés à plusieurs endroits mais
ne semblent encore une fois pas suffisants
pour leur faire porter seuls la responsabilité
de l’effondrement classique.
Jared Diamond qui consacre aux Mayas le chapitre
5 de son best-seller Effondrement met l’accent
sur ces causes environnementales, notamment
sur la déforestation conséquence de la fabrication
du stuc qui servait à blanchir les temples.
Le stuc c'est un enduit à base
de chaux, il faut brûler de grandes quantités
de calcaire pour oxyder le calcium qu’il
contient.
Et donc ça demande un approvisionnement en
bois très très important.
L’ornementation croissante des temples,
qui prenait part à la rivalité entre les
cités, pourrait avoir causé de graves déforestations,
entraînant des glissements de terrains, un
appauvrissement des sols, une baisse des précipitations,
etc.
Voilà pour trois causes qui ont pu influer,
en se combinant, sur le déclin de la civilisation
urbaine médiévale maya.
Et les survivants à toutes ces crises et
bien ils n’étaient pas au bout de leurs
peines et je continue la liste.
En effet, comme les autres peuples amérindiens,
les Mayas ont été gravement touchés par
les épidémies européennes.
Restés sans contacts avec le Vieux Monde
pendant des millénaires, les Indiens ne se
sont pas adaptés aux microbes et autres virus
qui ont affectés les européens, africains
et asiatiques dans ce laps de temps.
Alors quand arrive en 1511 dans l’est du
Yucatan une chaloupe de naufragés espagnols,
une grave épidémie ravage rapidement la
région.
Quand les européens entament la conquête
des dernières principautés mayas, elles
sont déjà très lourdement affaiblies par
ces nouvelles maladies.
Je viens d’en parler, à cela il faut également
ajouter de véritables épisodes de conquête
espagnole qui viennent en quelque sorte finir
le travail.
A partir de 1524, Francisco de Montejo et
Pedro de Alvarado, deux compagnons de Cortès
qui ont participé à la prise de Mexico,
mènent des expéditions pour contrôler ces
terres et se constituer de grandes fortunes
au nom du roi d’Espagne.
Après avoir listé ces causes, on n’est
à peine plus avancé, on ne peut que conclure
que c’est une conjugaison de facteurs qui
a contribué à cette disparition.
Mais si l’on n’arrive pas à se mettre
d’accord sur un facteur qui aurait causé
la disparition des mayas, c’est peut-être
tout simplement parce qu’ils n’ont pas
disparu.
Et quand je dis ça, c’est pas qu’il en
reste un ou deux perdus dans la forêt : les
mayas n’ont pas disparu du tout.
Le Mexique reste habité par des millions
de mayas, parlant des dizaines de langues
qui restent très proches de celles que parlaient
les habitants des fameuses ruines.
On s’en rend particulièrement compte quand
on prend le métro à Mexico, on croise des
profils, des silhouettes, des visages que
l’on retrouve gravés sur les stèles de
Palenque ou de Chichen Itza.
Les Mayas n’ont jamais disparu, ils ont
seulement abandonné leurs villes médiévales.
Il faudrait à présent, non plus parler de
disparition, mais de crise, même plutôt
de crise de la civilisation urbaine.
Les facteurs qu’on a décrits plus haut
ont conduit certaines des villes mayas à
être abandonnées, mais de nouveaux centres
urbains ont émergé par la suite, peut-être
pas bâtis en pierre avec d’aussi grands
temples blanchis à la chaux mais ces villes
étaient bien là, les espagnols qui ont dû
les assiéger pourraient en témoigner.
Si certaines villes ont été
abandonnées, cela n’a pas forcément été
le cas des campagnes environnantes qui pouvaient
rester très peuplées.
Car une fois les grands royaumes urbains disparus,
la plupart des problèmes qu’on a listés
disparaissent avec eux.
Plus besoin de faire la guerre pour des chefs
assoiffés de pouvoir, plus besoin de ravager
les forêts pour des prêtres mégalos, retour
à la bonne vieille principauté paysanne
qui pète pas plus haut que son cul et du
coup n’a pas trop de mal à survivre.
Les habitants ont sans doute fui les villes
et leurs conflits permanents pour se réfugier
dans les campagnes ou de nouvelles cités
secondaires.
Les mayas n’ont pas disparu, tout simplement
parce qu’ils avaient encore la possibilité
de vivre hors des villes, ce sont en définitive
ces éléments urbains, les plus fragiles
de leur société, qui ont succombé à cette
grande crise.
Quand on y pense c’est un peu effrayant,
dans notre cas au XXIe siècle, l’immense
majorité d’entre nous aurait bien du mal
s’il fallait vivre sans ville, pour se nourrir
ou pour se loger.
Si l’on pense souvent que les mayas ont
disparu c’est qu’encore une fois, ce que
l’on retient de leur histoire est uniquement
ce qui nous intéresse : une affaire de mystère,
de grand bouleversement et de redécouverte
sensationnelle par de courageux explorateurs.
La vérité, comme souvent, est plus complexe
et moins sexy comme j’espère avoir réussi
à vous le faire entrevoir.
C’est la fin de cet épisode, j’espère
qu’il vous a plu.
Vous pouvez le partager et vous abonner à
la chaîne et également poser vos questions
en commentaire, j’y répondrai avec plaisir.
Enfin, si vous voulez me soutenir c’est
sur Tipeee que ça se passe.
Vous trouverez le lien ici dans le petit « i
», en barre d’information et sur la page
d’accueil de ma chaîne.
A bientôt !